we had a brilliant art director on this
film brand McEntee who really brought a
tremendous amount to the look of the
film and Gary you can weigh in here too
but the the the feeling of the film the
costumes what are the nights I remember
fairly late at night we were having
pizza and some type of alcoholic
beverage and we were designing bells
ballroom dress that night and it was
Gary said yellows nice and Brian said
well how about a blue and gold think
it's a blue and gold was very much kind
of compelling colors together and it
felt like a royal kind of regal ball and
I it just daunted me there's like just a
bunch of guys eating pizza deciding what
Bell's gonna whatever girl's gonna wear
at Halloween for years it was sad but
thankfully it worked out and we had
people like Laura Palmer I cook on the
on the crew and Brenda on the crew to
actually give an intelligent point of
view about what those characters might
actually wear the ballroom itself was a
was an outgrowth of trying to move the
camera get the audience swept away and
and Roger Hughie had a storyboard of
that sequence I think so maybe you can
speak on that more intelligently than I
and Brenda - and Brenda - well yeah it
was it was interesting because we
storyboarded at first and and we're
thinking ahead to how could we use this
space this was a new freedom for us
really you know because prior to this I
can't think of any oh yes I guess basil
had a clock environment that he ran
around in but generally we didn't have
environment this was a first time we
really did an environment that we linger
in and so it was kind of exciting to
think about all right how can we move
the camera and how what's going to give
this it's swirl what's gonna give it its
lift it's being of lift I decided oh
let's let's go up to the let's go up to
the painted ceiling let's look at them
from above the chandelier and that was
and then and then he was up there in the
clouds and I moved the camera down and
that's the swish of her skirt because he
was up there I was down here
it was it was incredible but I think the
other thing that was freeing was because
we sort of talked to the animators a
little bit about it too because that's
always the worry when you move the
camera around too much it changes the
angle and the characters which I know
can be a nightmare but they said we're
game so we went for it was great the CG
guys actually put in I remember like a
triangular like a pyramidal shape to
represent Belle when they roughed out
the the ball Jim Ellen who's here
tonight actually was was like nutty
enough to say yes to this whole idea
yeah and the beast was like a plinth you
know he was like a rectangular and these
two like are sliding around this and
then somehow magically I mean I think
especially James that was Baxter Baxter
thank you James Baxter who was so
brilliant with moving figures through
space I don't know that guy just has a
like a computer mind he can because the
cameras moving in they're moving and
he's amazing amazing animation yeah and
then and then it's emotional too it's
not just whoosh whoosh whoosh you know
it's not just like flying your jet
fighter around the room and I have
something it's not the first time that
we ever saw that done with animation I
don't remember ever seeing a scene as
huge as that with us you know the
figures moving around yeah I remember at
the time when we first saw it it was
astonishing it really was yeah it was
you know before five years before the
toy stores of the world and it now we
have the computing power that it took to
do that scene on our cell phones
probably but we always had a back-up
plan we had a back-up plan that if the
render didn't work we would do what we
call kind of an Ice Capades plan and it
would be a single spotlight around the
do characters dance ooh turn off the
ballroom but thankfully our computer
guys made it work and actually see the
whole ballroom now so thank you Jim
thank you Scott